politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'effe de
politique votre rendez-vous politique du
dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisode 231 et
mon premier invité pour cette année 2023
et le vice-président et porte-parole du
département des Yvelines Philippe
Benassaya
[Musique]
politique
bonsoir Philippe benattaya bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous et à ce soir vous êtes
donc vice-président du département des
Yvelines délégués à la communication et
aux portes-parola membres des
républicains vous avez été maire de
Bois-d'Arcy entre 2014 et 2020 et puis
député de la 11e circonscription des
Yvelines entre 2020 et 2022 vous si j'ai
donc au conseil départemental depuis
2015 l'année commence avec la
traditionnelle cérémonie des vœux à la
population même si on avait un peu perdu
l'habitude depuis la crise sanitaire le
Conseil départemental des Yvelines a
décidé une nouvelle fois de renouer avec
cette cérémonie avec le Conseil
Départemental des Hauts-de-Seine demande
de fusion des deux assemblées
départementales et toujours sur la table
ça fait des années que ce projet est sur
la table avant que donc pour l'instant
ça n'a toujours pas abouti est-ce que en
2023 il y aura des des avancées dans ce
dossier
alors c'est vrai que pour certains ça
peut être un serpent de mer la fusion
mais en fait non quand on le vit au
quotidien c'est tout autre on vit
vraiment
l'acheminement vers au pire une
mutualisation entre nos départements au
mieux une véritable fusion on y
travaille depuis des années il faut
savoir quand même que on a pris un peu
de retard pourquoi d'abord parce que
c'est la vie et que c'est surtout le
l'objectif c'était l'objectif de deux
hommes Pierre Bédier Patrick devaitdjan
avec la malheureuse disparition de
Patrick devait-jan le projet a pris un
peu de retard que le nouveau président
des Hauts-de-Seine monsieur Siffredi a
comblé donc on y travaille on mutualise
il y a beaucoup de services qui sont
déjà mutualisés on siège en commun
régulièrement nos deux départements
sièges en commun très souvent ce qu'on
appelle c'est le pays qui siège
c'est-à-dire l'établissement public
intercommunal qui siège c'est-à-dire le
département des Yvelines et le
département des Hauts-de-Seine donc ça
avance mais il faut être deux pour
avancer il faut qu'il y ait d'un côté
les collectivités et de l'autre l'État
le problème vous allez me dire qui est
fautif dans l'affaire je vais vous
répondre l'état parce que c'est l'État
qui bloque en général les fusions de
département c'est assez rare confusionne
ça c'est rare que des départements
fusionnent pas beaucoup d'exemples
autour de moi mais là si vous voulez si
les Yvelines et les Hauts-de-Seine
fusionnent ça va être un super
département il y a eu le dossier un
petit peu compliqué de la métropole de
Lyon d'un peu dans dans ce cas là c'est
ça alors pourquoi est-ce qu'une fusion
entre les deux départements serait
bénéfiques à la fois pour les Yvelinois
et pour les altoé d'abord parce que nous
avons nous sommes deux départements
dynamiques nous allons peut-être en
parler mais nous avons une très forte
tous les deux tous les deux départements
est très fort politique d'investissement
à faible taux d'endettement deux
départements les plus riches de France
les budgets absolument et puis si j'ai
un caricaturé j'ai envie de dire que les
Hauts-de-Seine c'est le dynamisme
entrepreneurial c'est la défense et
l'Arena etc
et puis les Yvelines c'est l'espace
c'est aussi le patrimoine c'est aussi la
culture c'est aussi une entreprise parce
que lorsque vous totalisez le nombre
d'entreprises qu'il y a dans les
Hauts-de-Seine dans les Yvelines c'est
quand même extrêmement important donc ça
vaut le coup est-ce que l'État n'est pas
réticent parce que ça formerait
justement un département trop puissant
par rapport aux autres départements
franciliens notamment j'ai entendu dire
ça j'ai entendu dire que ça allait être
un état dans l'état ce qui est
totalement faux puisque les
collectivités
souffrent aujourd'hui surtout de
recentralisation de l'État et pas de
décentralisation et c'est pour ça que ça
bloque c'est parce que l'État est en
train de se recentraliser on n'a jamais
connu ça d'ailleurs oui c'est ça c'est
ça et puis aussi il y a des il y a des
des convergences c'est l'ouest parisien
c'est l'ouest parisien qui qui se
développe de manière forte et donc voilà
pourquoi on mutualise énormément en ce
moment quoi alors avec plus de 3
millions d'habitants cette fusion il vit
notre scène ferait de ce futur
département le plus grand en termes de
population en France alors ce soir là
lors de la cérémonie des vœux une
demande d'une plus grande
décentralisation également été évoquée
par Pierre Bellier vous venez de
l'évoquer pierre Bédié qui a dit je cite
dans le domaine de la décentralisation
rien ne se passe rien ne se fait et je
dirais même plus gravement rien ne se
pense alors vous souhaitez vous plus de
compétences au départementale qu'est-ce
que vous demandez exactement à l'état
honnêtement il y a tout à fait raison je
crois qu'on a jamais connu une période
aussi centralisatrice quand France
aujourd'hui quoi je suis étonné de la
part d'ailleurs du président Macron qui
est plutôt on va dire à libéral de
droite ou de gauche c'est pas moi de
juger c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui qui
connaît un petit peu le tissu économique
le tissu voilà et je comprends pas
pourquoi mais d'un autre côté c'est un
c'est un serviteur de l'État dans un
serviteur de l'État son équipe sont tous
des serviteurs de l'État des énarques
etc qui ont une vision très parisienne
très très centralisatrice très jacobine
de la politique sont souvent des
personnes qui ne sont pas élus qui ne
l'ont jamais été lui-même d'ailleurs
donc ils n'ont pas cette cette fibre ce
tissu
des territoires et de toute façon c'est
peine perdent pour eux je pense et c'est
peine perdu pour pour ce gouvernement et
même pour les gouvernements futurs vous
voyez je suis je suis très très objectif
les territoires prendront de plus en
plus importantes dans les politiques
publiques françaises et européenne parce
que c'est nous qui donnons le la sur le
terrain et sinon qui avons apporté les
solutions je vais vous donner juste un
exemple covid qui arrive les problèmes
du covid c'est globalement les
collectivités avec la distribution des
masques ici
le centre le vélo de drone qui sait qui
s'est transformé en centre vaccination
centre médical de vaccination etc donc
vous voyez que ce sont les territoires
qui attirent aussi une attractivité du
territoire pour les entreprises je pense
que c'est peine perdu le Jacoby 19
français est une vieille idée qu'on
apprend encore dans les grandes écoles
françaises pour créer des des petits
marquis de l'État mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le pouvoir est dans les
territoires et on le voit tous les jours
on en reparlera peut-être sur la
circulation douce sur les entreprises
sur le social sur l'éducation etc etc
alors l'actualité au conseil
départemental des Yvelines en ce début
d'année c'est aussi cette perquisition
qui a eu lieu donc au siège à Versailles
elle vise pierre Bédié le président dans
le cadre d'une enquête pour atteinte à
la probité cette enquête concerne une
subvention départementale de plus d'un
million d'euros versé en 2018 pour la
construction d'une maison médicale un
projet porté par une société civile
immobilière codée tenue par le
beau-frère de Pierre Bédier alors
l'enquête est toujours en couple en
cours il y a le principe de présomption
d'innocence évidemment est-ce que le
Conseil départemental souhaite réagir à
cette affaire non parce qu'en fait
l'institution n'est pas visée vous venez
de le dire dans votre dans votre topo
que c'est une enquête qui vise pierre
bélier malheureusement mais qui vise
quand même le président du département
mais une subvention de départementale
et puis en plus je veux pas commenter
une décision de justice on va pas le
faire ici je le ferai pas ailleurs non
plus donc c'est en cours c'est quelque
chose qui nous affecte bien évidemment
parce que ça touche
le Mantois enfin c'est quelque chose qui
se passe à Mantes-la-Jolie ça touche
notre président bien évidemment mais
l'institution en tant que tel n'est pas
ne sont pas un dysfonctionnement des
services du département ou autre qui
font qu'il y a une perquisition quand
vous dites au département c'est une
affaire qui est pendante comme on dit
qui va être longue je pense pour le pour
le président Bédié mais c'est de toute
façon moi je vous dire on fait corps on
fait corps dans ce dans ce sens où on
laisse la justice bien évidemment
travailler et puis on en reparlera mais
je vais pas je vais pas commenter une
décision de justice ici quoi 2023
nouvelle année nouveau budget pour le
département dans un contexte marqué par
l'inflation et l'augmentation des coûts
énergétiques le département a voté un
budget de 1,9 milliards d'euros cette
année alors quels sont les grandes
lignes de ce budget 2023 donc vous savez
on est à département qui est très très
bien géré vous avez vous l'avez dit vous
l'avez très très bien dit on a un budget
d'un million un milliard 900 millions
d'euros c'est beaucoup vous imaginez
l'un des plus importants pour un
département en France imaginez si on
fusionne avec des Hauts-de-Seine parce
que ça donnerait
les plus important c'est pas les
chiffres mais je vous en donner un quand
même parce que ça va vous donner un
petit peu l'importance de notre
département qu'est-ce qu'un qu'est-ce
qu'un département excusez-moi je vais
prendre juste 10 secondes qu'est-ce
qu'un département un département c'est
un échelon de proximité qui donne des
réponses au quotidien sur l'éducation
les collèges sur le social le
médico-social sur les routes sur les
plans de circulation douce
je passe l'aide aux communaux rurales
via plusieurs agences dont notamment
l'agence ingénierie que j'ai pris les
pompiers les pompiers le 10 et de
cerveau on est contre ce que ça ce que
ça ce que ça ce que ça implique dans le
quotidien des Français et des yvelinois
notamment et bien dans ce budget là nous
avons
voté un plan d'investissement de 600
millions d'euros je crois je suis pas
sûr vérifier c'est vous qui êtes le
journaliste mais je crois que c'est l'un
des plus importants plein
d'investissement en France aujourd'hui
dans les départements donc c'est un un
département très dynamique faiblement
endetté ou endetté à très court terme
donc je suis plutôt fier de ce budget
qui a été côté et plutôt fier de ces 600
millions d'investissements alors si je
découpe un peu le budget donc 712
millions pour l'émission de solidarité
38% du budget 508 millions donc pour
l'attractivité territoriale 468 millions
pour l'enfant là jeunesse et donc 6 % du
budget consacré à la gestion du
département le département avance donc
comme vous venez de justement de le
faire un faible recours à l'endettement
dans sa gestion c'est même l'un des
départements les moins endettés de
France alors qu'est-ce qui explique ces
résultats économiques aujourd'hui vous
savez quand on est en crise c'est comme
dans une commune quand on est en crise
la première le premier réflexe qu'il
faut avoir c'est pas le la fébrilité ou
l'immobilisme c'est l'action il faut
agir on est en crise en France depuis
tout le temps on va pas dire que c'est
aujourd'hui avec la l'énergie hier c'est
le covid avant-hier c'était les baisses
des dotations de l'État aux collectivité
et ainsi de suite institut on a toujours
été en crise bon donc l'objectif c'est
de c'est justement d'agir et bien le
département agit énormément nous allons
parler avec plusieurs sujets les
collèges les maisons médicales etc les
circulations douces
ce département a une attractivité
incroyable d'abord on a beaucoup
d'entreprises il faut pas oublier que
c'est sur les entreprises qui créent la
richesse c'est pas le département qui
crée la richesse le département
redistribue une richesse qu'il possède
par
beaucoup de mécanismes on va pas rentrer
dans les détails mais notamment les
entreprises notamment les entreprises et
nous avons un tissu économique très
important sur la scène mais également
aussi à Saint-Quentin bien évidemment
qui est un pôle économique et
d'innovation incroyable etc etc donc ce
qui fait la force de ce département
c'est sa diversité sa diversité
économique sa diversité sociale sa
diversité patrimoniale culturelle etc
nous avons une chance inouïe franchement
je je suis pas en train de vous allez me
dire je suis porte-parole donc je vais
pas dire du mal du département mais
vraiment vraiment quand on compare et
que je vous dis voilà c'est 2 milliards
le budget du département c'est 600
millions d'investissements on a presque
tout dit
on va parler maintenant des projets
d'investissement justement pour l'année
en cours le département gère les
collèges
90000 collégiens yvinois bénéficieront
donc jusqu'en 2026 d'un cartable
numérique 19 millions d'euros ils seront
consacrés cette année alors concrètement
que contient ce cartable numérique alors
d'abord c'est c'est une des compétences
du département c'est à dire l'innovation
le numérique je crois qu'on va
distribuer au total 130 000 cartables
numériques ce qui est énorme vous avez
dit 19 millions d'euros tout oui
j'aurais mis un petit peu moins j'aurais
17 millions mais tant mieux si c'est 19
millions c'est un cartable numérique qui
va être donc distribué notamment dans
les collèges forcément puisque c'est la
compétence du Département c'est un
cartable numérique qui va dans lesquels
il va y avoir beaucoup de ressources
pédagogiques et beaucoup de ressources
pour que les élèves
yvelinois puisse travailler en toute
autonomie sur des sur des sur des
ressources pédagogiques
histoire-géographie maths de manière
souvent ludique d'ailleurs et souvent
très très pédagogique c'est l'avenir
c'est un débat aussi certains sont pas
forcément d'accord avec avec cette idée
de cartable numérique mais aujourd'hui
ça fait presque tout le monde s'équipe
de cartable numérique y compris dans les
communes aujourd'hui et donc le
département fait un gros effort quand
même 130 000 cartes numériques c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup plus qu'on parle
des collèges justement un nouveau
collège devrait voir le jour dans les
Yvelines en 2025 à Sartrouville un coup
de 80 millions d'euros est évoqué pris
en charge par le département et la ville
alors le nouveau collège fera 600 places
j'imagine que vu le contexte une
nouvelle établissement prendra également
en compte des enjeux environnementaux
oui mais en plus ça fait partie du plan
du plan ambitieux de notamment
d'investissement du département pour les
collèges il y a pas que il y a pas que
ce collège là il y a aussi la
reconstruction totale du Collège Albert
Einstein de de Magny-les-Hameaux les
collèges sont en mouvement dans les dans
les Yvelines c'est et on prend en compte
plusieurs choses la capacité d'accueil
mais également
l'environnement
voilà tout ce qui est en jeu climatique
aussi on est en train de créer des
collèges de point zéro ou 3.0 dans les
Yvelines on construit plus collège des
années 70 comme j'ai par exemple dans ma
ville à Bois-d'Arcy j'ai un collège qui
est très bien parfait il est super il
s'appelle le collège Mozart mais il date
des années 70 on voit la construction
l'esthétique qui est qui est très
ancienne aujourd'hui maintenant les
collèges sont passés à une à la vitesse
supérieure avec avec la transition
énergétique en prise en compte il va
falloir espérer réduire les factures
pour réduire les factures et tout ça
donc tout est pris en compte les
l'éclairage LED enfin toutes ces choses
là on peut plus faire sans l'enjeu
l'enjeu environnemental aujourd'hui
Laurence début d'année le débat sur
l'uniforme à l'école est revenu alors
une loi donc portée par
le rassemblement national mais la
majorité pourrait revenir prochainement
donc sur ce sujet à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable à des uniformes dans les
collèges des Yvelines
j'ai pas votre âge moi je suis un petit
peu plus âgé que vous de quelques mois
mais j'ai connu j'ai connu la fin de
l'uniforme et quand je revois les photos
de classe lorsqu'on était en CP on CE1
ça donnait une image plutôt homogène de
la diversité sociale française ça
donnait une image de cohésion aussi et
aujourd'hui avec le numérique les
réseaux sociaux
je pense qu'il faut une protection moi
je suis plutôt favorable à l'uniforme je
vois que la majorité
gouvernementale
réfléchi à la question
la première dame la force Lady comme on
dit c'est Macron Brigitte Macron y est
plutôt favorable aussi alors sous quelle
forme uniforme j'en sais rien j'ai pas
réfléchi mais mais c'est vrai que ça
pourrait être une bonne idée pour
justement gommer les inégalités alors
l'investissement dans les Yvelines c'est
aussi la question des transports qui est
une compétence régionale alors que les
travaux du Grand Paris se poursuivent le
département soutien cette année le
projet Éole à hauteur de 43 millions
d'euros pour relier donc Mantes-la-Jolie
à la défense les transports sont de plus
en plus compliqués pour les habitants de
grandes couronnes les voyageurs n'ont
pas forcément l'impression que ça
s'améliore malgré les augmentations
tarifaires comment le département il
travaille malgré le fait que ce ne soit
pas sa compétence directe mais vous avez
tout à fait raison je crois que vous
avez vous avez souligné la dichotomie
qui a entre la modernisation des
transports et la satisfaction des
usagers c'est
quelque chose qui est qui va falloir
régler mais c'est vrai que les
transports deviennent aujourd'hui le
problème numéro 1 des Franciliens en
général et des Yvelines en particulier
il y a le projet vous l'avez rappelé
c'est plus de 40 millions d'euros je
crois c'est ça vous avez 33 millions
d'euros exactement 43 cette année donc
vous voyez que c'est aussi un gros
investissement il y a le T13 que nous
venons d'inaugurer en 2022 je crois que
c'était en juillet 2002 le département
est consacre 25 millions d'euros au
travail et c'est dans mon canton de
Saint-Cyr-l'École avec ma binôme Sonia
Bro qui est maire de Saint-Cyr-l'École
on a inauguré pour la tranche bien sûr
ça sert l'école Saint-Germain-en-Laye et
notre travail et nous travaillons
aujourd'hui pour le prolongement de de
la ligne de Saint-Germain-en-Laye HR
donc entre les halls manquent la défense
le T13 ça bouge ça bouge maintenant il
faut régler le problème de la régularité
des fréquences de tous ces sujets là
mais je suis un peu pas déçu mais
m'interroge souvent parce que c'est vrai
que je sais que les usagers sont
insatisfaits que c'est pas forcément une
compétence départementale c'est une
compétence régionale c'est vrai et de
l'autre il y a un effort incroyable
quand vous voyez des nouvelles rames un
peu partout pas simplement d'ailleurs
dans les Yvelines vous vous dites que ça
bouge beaucoup quand même dans les
transports en Île-de-France et donc un
jour il va falloir que il y ait cette
cohérence entre satisfaction des usagers
et modernisation des transports
peut-être lorsque le Grand Paris Express
sera achevé on verra dans le dossier de
transport il y a aussi les mobilités
douces le département a voté une aide de
880000 euros pour l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines afin qu'elles
développent de nouvelles pistes
cyclables alors en investit pour que
même en grande couronne finalement le
réflexe voiture ne soit pas utilisée oui
alors c'est compliqué parce parce que
bon on peut dire c'est génial
circulation douce c'est vrai d'ailleurs
on y a investi on est investi beaucoup
dans le département des îles on a un
plan vélo vous le savez 2022 2027 qui
est très très important plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros donc c'est
c'est nécessité mais on va pas tout
régler on va pas aller en vélo
au travail forcément aller en vélo à la
défense le plus pratique voilà donc il
faut dire voilà il faut une politique de
transport mais il faut aussi une
politique de circulation douce et de et
de plan vélo pour pouvoir à la fois
allier
nécessité professionnelle et loisirs
alors l'investissement c'est aussi
l'aide aux communes 87 millions d'euros
cette année les départements sont
souvent très fiers de dire qu'ils sont
le premier partenaire oui des communes
en tant que sa mère vous vous le savez
c'est c'est important quelle est
l'importance de ces subventions pour les
maires des connus je pense que sans
l'investissement du département je pense
qu'on fait pas grand chose honnêtement
moi dans mon dans mon mandat 2014 2020 à
Bois-d'Arcy j'ai géré j'ai créé un
gymnase et rénover un autre gymnase j'ai
créé une maison des associations
sans le département j'aurais pas pu
rénover ces deux gymnases là j'aurais
pas pu rénover des écoles j'aurais pas
pu faire les pistes la plus j'ai faite
alors il y a d'autres partenaires il y a
la communauté d'agglomération nous à
Bois-d'Arcy on a vers sa Grand-Parc il y
a également la région et puis parfois
que de cerise il y a l'état mais c'est
vrai que le département les départements
le premier partenaires des collectivités
être mère et conseil départemental à un
sens ce que je veux dire par là où on
s'est régional c'est un sens parce que
on arrive plus facilement à établir des
partenariats et à faire pardonner moi
rentrer de l'argent dans les communes
puis aussi donc la santé un secteur en
crise les Yvelines sont menacés par la
désertification médicale quelles sont
les stratégies politiques qui peuvent
être mises en place par le département
pour lutter contre ce phénomène bon on
l'a vu pendant le covid les urgences
sont totalement saturés les hôpitaux
sont saturés même sans covid aujourd'hui
on parle des transports qui fonctionnent
pas très bien mais je pense que le
milieu hospitalier ne fonctionne pas
toujours très bien avec de vieux
problèmes qui sont liés parfois souvent
aux 35 heures et qui reviennent
aujourd'hui avec avec les crises les
différentes crises que le secteur a
connu donc il faut trouver des des
palliatifs il faut trouver de nouvelles
idées et le département c'est lancé dans
plusieurs idées le financement de maison
médicale je crois que c'est 32 millions
d'euros sur la table du département pour
pour créer des missions des médicaments
alors on a créé quelques-unes déjà celle
de Bonnel puis il y en a d'autres aussi
donc ça c'est c'est une réponse au lieu
d'aller aux urgences forcément et et en
Bouteiller les urgences allant d'abord
déjà dans des maisons médicales mais
aussi il y a d'autres idées il y a le
bus il y a le bus médical du département
qui qui tourne qui tourne avec avec pour
aider soit les les femmes en difficulté
ou les enfants etc donc on essaye de
trouver des idées qui permettent à la
population de pas se ruer forcément
l'hôpital aux urgences mais peut-être
passer par les maisons médical je vous
précise quand même que l'Île-de-France
paradoxalement est un désert médical
voilà donc pas que les Yvelines mais
l'Île-de-France est un désert médical
l'année sera aussi marqué par les
événements sportifs dans le département
le Paris-Nice s'élancera le 5 mars de la
verrière puis en juillet sera au tour du
Tour de France de faire étables donc à
au Vélodrome national pour la dernière
étape traditionnelle jusqu'au
Champs-Élysées à Paris il y a un ADN
très fort entre les Yvelines et le
cyclisme oui oui IAM on en parle pas
souvent d'ailleurs de la de la relation
alors je vais m'y atteler en tant que
parole mais on parle pas souvent de
l'ADN sport Yvelines d'abord parce qu'on
a le PG maintenant à Poissy avant à
Saint-Germain il y a le vélodrome on a
quand même des équipements publics
extraordinaires on a le Paris-Nice qui
part des Yvelines comme vous l'avez dit
on va voir le Tour de France on va voir
plusieurs compétitions olympiques
dont notamment ici à Saint-Quentin pour
les Jeux Olympiques de 20 4 c'est une
vraie terre de à la fois de vélo mais
c'est aussi une terre sportive et
lorsqu'on rassemble justement 78 et 92
vous avez l'Arena vous avez la racine
vous avez dans le 92 et puis on a puis
on a oui on a le foot aussi j'ai parlé
du PSG mais je voudrais aussi parler du
Football Club de Versailles qui est
première je crois aujourd'hui en
National pour la montée éventuellement
la saison champion d'automne donc donc
ils sont plutôt bien parti donc voilà
c'est une vraie terre de sport on
investit beaucoup dans le sport aussi
dans le sport aussi quotidien dans les
collèges etc donc
je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on fasse un
effort de communication pour expliquer
que je crois qu'on a quatre compétitions
olympiques dans dans les Yvelines c'est
quand même c'est quand même pas rien
quoi on va y revenir juste avant je
voudrais rebondir sur le PSG vous avez
vu comme nous cette interview dan
Hidalgo dans Le Parisien qui donc évoqué
qu'il ne souhaite pas vendre le parc le
Parc des Princes au Paris Saint-Germain
car le livre
que vous connaissez bien député des
Yvelines et ancien maire de Poissy a
évoqué qu'il pourrait éventuellement
rendre service pour donc un futur stade
du PSG à Poissy il est revenu dessus il
est revenu ensuite dessus mais comment
est-ce que vous vous voyez donc le PSG
un club qui vient des Yvelines comment
est-ce que vous vous voyez cette cette
affaire et est-ce que le PSG devrait
se rendre donc pour ce nouveau stade en
banlieue et pourquoi pas revenir dans
les Yvelines j'aimerais être moi au bord
de au conseil au bureau je sais pas
comment on appelle ça du PSG pour voir
ce qui se dit parce que c'est vrai que
j'ai pas l'information directe sur le
PSG je crois car le livre puisqu'il
connaît très très bien dossier du PSG il
est revenu dessus d'ailleurs sur ces
déclarations c'est un club parisien
ivino à Paris Saint-Germain donc
on est un peu à cheval sur les deux
créer un nouveau stade dans les Yvelines
c'est pas demain matin voilà c'est ça
coûte énormément
on a déjà investi beaucoup dans le
vélodrome il y a quelques années je sais
pas exactement s'il faut que péger
joue ces matchs dans les ulides moi
personnellement vous allez me dire je
vais de la vieille je l'aime au Parc des
Princes depuis 1975 c'est pour vous dire
j'y allais quand il y avait encore les
un peu les daleb au PSG donc je suis
très attaché au parc mais je comprends
aussi que le parc est assez étroit
maintenant compte tenu des
investissements
qatari et de et de de l'avenir de ce
club qui est un club dans le top five le
top 5 le top 6 le top 7 européen c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui le parc est un peu
même si beaucoup d'efforts de faits dans
le parc aujourd'hui quand on y va on
voit la différence avec le parc il y a
10 ans donc à suivre comme on dit on va
voir ce qui va se passer est-ce qu'il va
y avoir une rénovation institut du par
des Princes compliqués parce que c'est
pas compliqué
par des Princes sur le périple qui est
déjà une prouesse architecturale
incroyable dans les années 70 ou dans
les Yvelines à suivre à suivre je vais
maintenant sur les Jeux Olympiques que
vous ok donc cette année sera aussi une
année de préparation pour ces JO Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques aussi donc
en 2024 à Paris les Yvelines y prendront
leur part avec des épreuves de cyclisme
sur piste au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais aussi le
VTT sur la colline d'Élancourt
l'équitation et le pentathlon moderne au
château de Versailles le marathon et le
vélo passeront également sur les routes
du département puis les épreuves de golf
pour terminer au Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines comment se
débarque se prépare vous avez tout dit
je crois qu'on va se préparer énormément
d'abord on a on a il y a une toute une
politique de de de de sensibilisation
puisqu'il y a des villes les villes
partenaires les villes sportives les
villes olympiques comme on dit dans les
dans les Yvelines on s'y prépare les
communes vont essayer aussi de de
préparer des événements avec la jeunesse
le département également
c'est c'est important on a on a un
conseiller départemental délégué qui en
charge du de jeux olympiques et du sport
au département on a un service qui est
qui est très concentré sur le sur le sur
le sujet
c'est dans notre ADN comme on l'a dit
donc je pense qu'on va réussir on va
réussir l'événement parce que c'est
quand même on a vous avez parlé du golf
j'ai pas entendu oui il y a le golf
aussi donc on a quand même énormément de
de
discipline olympique je crois qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup d'événements ylinois
ciblés sur les communes et la jeunesse
pour préparer cet événement merci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS Philippe Benassaya
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle donc
que vous êtes vice-président du conseil
départemental des Yvelines en charge de
la communication et du porte-parola
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine mon invité
sera alors le maire de La Verrière
Nicolas Dainville très bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]